i just can't get a vibe on it i think
the bengals have a good enough defense
to stop matthew stafford i like joe
burrow this is mostly my heart though
because i'm an lsu fan my money is lsu
baby
and i think joe burrow
learned something
in that game when he got sacked nine
times and i'm picking the cincinnati
bengals everything tells me that the
rams should win this game
defense wins championships i want joe
bird to win this game i love this kid's
swag he's got a chain over a turtleneck
who loves that more than me
i do think though
the magic runs out bill's got cincinnati
i'm taking los angeles i think you're
wrong paul i got 200 bucks says you're
wrong this is how confident i am here's
my little italian swag from
hanging with you i don't need the points
i'll bet you straight up okay i'll bet
you straight up too